welcome to the heavy spoilers show
I'm definition your host with the most
puns and this video were breaking down
episode 4 of Westworld season 3 the
mind-bending entry has a lot going on
and throughout this video we're going to
be discussing the major plot points and
giving our theories on what could be
happening in the future of the show
there will be heavy spoilers here so if
you don't want anything ruined then I
highly recommend that you turn off now
make sure you subscribe to the channel
as we'll be breaking down the entire
season and please drop a thumbs up if
you enjoy the video without the way
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into our breakdown a Westworld
season 3 episode 4
when you already know we're not with a
[ __ ] okay so the title of the episode
the mother of X Isles
comes from a sonic called the new
Colossus by Emma Lazarus Emma wrote the
poem in the late 18-hundreds to raise
money for a pedestal on Statue of
Liberty and this was later placed upon
it the poem itself was about the Statue
and how it was similar to the Colossus
in Rhodes the interpretation behind it
is that the statue is a maternal figure
that symbolizes the dawning of America
and how women will play a much bigger
pond Society this is reflected in this
episode where we see Dolores rising up
in more ways than one and I'll literally
mean in more ways than one we opened
with William aka the man in black buddy
car remember I'm sorry a terrible he's
held up in his home he's slowly having a
mental breakdown and is constantly
questioning his own reality the last
time we saw him he killed his own
daughter Emily and then made it to the
forge only to find a host of her in
which she told him that they'd been
testing for fidelity though it did
appear that he was a replica similar to
James Dallas we do learn in this episode
that the Emily he saw was likely a
hallucination so we can gather from that
that he is indeed still real however he
is now trapped in his own personal hell
and this is exemplified by the fact he
wakes up in the bathtub that his wife
killed herself in an apparition of Emily
appears reminding him of the horrendous
things that he's done and the
conversation they have makes him really
question whether he's in power or if
it's the park that's ruined his life he
doesn't know whether he's a machine or
not and is definitely something really
weird going on Charlotte appears and
snaps him out of it
and it finally seems like she's past the
identity crisis that she was having last
week we learn who is really within Hale
this time and there is a twist that I
personally didn't see coming I have to
admit that I was a bit disappointed with
the outcome of it it was solved what we
theorized last week with her being Wyatt
and then an I really look we'll get into
that later but I do think it breaks the
rules in several ways and does sort of
feel like a cheat Charlotte states that
she needs William to come out and cast a
vote that will make the company private
however this turns out to be a ruse
Charlotte actually escorts him to a
mental
facility and in doing so takes over his
shares in voting power now she does
mention that serac stole code from Delos
over 20 years ago and though this line
is brushed over it could show that he
had a mole in the corporation which has
enabled him to grow to this point 20
years ago
the real hale of course wouldn't have
been in the position she was all likely
even working for Delos and thus it could
be a number of people the first person
it could be they have seen people
theorizes Arnold
however he was killed 34 years before
the first season so I think that the
most likely candidates for it a Ford or
William I doubt it's the latter because
it's his company but the former was
always a wild card so rack is thought to
be just a human manifestation or rather
fake person created by Rehoboam and it
could be that it stole the code itself
when being created though Ford has never
been discussed when mentioning the
creation of the machine he may have
worked on it and in doing so this is how
it was able to get the data now I do
believe that serac is just a front for a
whole bomb and he exists within this
digital world that's a simulation within
a simulation when Hale went to meet him
last week she had to Don VR glasses to
see him and later in this episode we
learn that these glasses can fully
create a fake reality and show whatever
Ciroc wished them to he's left no
digital footprint and in a world like
this they've stayed that that is
impossible so maybe we should take them
at the word and serac is actually this
impossible human because he's a creation
of the machine we don't know for
definite yet but yeah that's just where
my mind is going so far
Hale mentions the project in Sector 16
and as we learn last season this was the
resurrection of James Delos from here we
could have been Arden Dolores with a
very similar scene to the second season
and as we can tell from the black bars
that dominate the screen this is a
simulation the aspect ratio cuts back
and forth between the real and simulated
reality so we can get a grip on what's
fake and what isn't and we learn about
the five pearls that Dolores took out
with her we also see Rehoboam scan the
world and it picks up divergence I think
the fact that we constantly cut to this
one in the reality with Caleb does add
weight to this being a simulation to the
shape of the circle is the same as
Rehoboam and is able to detect anomalies
and I've
timelines at the moment I think on the
real will is actually far in the future
and in ruin and Rehoboam is just a
simulation of the past this is how it is
able to tell the future so accurately
and decide where things are diverging
it's because it already knows the future
as it's already happened for the machine
it's recreating the world including West
world which would have existed there but
the complex programs have managed to
break free which has caused the
divergence I believe that we see the
truth of this and Saric story and which
he tells of his childhood namely the
destruction of Paris this could have
happened everywhere and thus people
resort to living in a simulation so they
could get away from the horrors of the
real world narcotics are digital in this
world and yeah there's just stuff
constantly indicating that this is
what's going on season one and two dealt
with different timelines and season
three is clearly dealing with different
realities I think Dolores has gone in
there to rescue older hosts such as
Caleb that were highly skilled but
suffered a cruel fate and this will be
how she will amass her army to take down
insight on the outside the poster for
Westworld season three does show a host
dying in the desert in front of a
destroyed City and do you think and this
is the case here the alternate theory is
that it's a prediction program that
works out all of the possible avenues of
the future and then presents them we are
seeing one version of this simulated
reality in which the synths rise up and
serac is attempting to use the data
collected from this to stop Dolores
either way this show does a great job of
keeping you guessing and I'm thoroughly
enjoying coming up with different
theories as I watch it Bernard and
Stubbs are lying low and after swimming
to the shore they're here to track down
Dolores Bernard has a device that can
freeze hosts and this will likely help
him massively in the fight against her
Stubb says that Dolores is copied MC
however we do know that this is ko Nels
his bodyguard it seems like they're
attempting to replicate several
real-world figures who as we learn in
this episode of the bodyguard Hale and
the leader of the Yakuza now it is
possible that she's also going to
replicate William - as in the show hell
takes a pinprick of blood from him
though I've never taken this as being a
necessary requirement to make duplicates
it was clearly carried out for a reason
and it could be that they wish to copy
more members of the board however we
also see Dolores drawing blood from
someone later
in order to break through an encryption
program so it could also be because Hale
wishes to unearth the secrets that
William has within Delos they clear out
Dempsey's bank account and Caleb gets to
go cold shopping like something out
grand theft auto elsewhere Mavis with
serac and she agrees to take down
Dolores in exchange for being reunited
with a daughter in host heaven he
apparently wishes to get the data that
Delos collected on all humankind so that
he can more accurately predict the
future he takes it to the point of
divergence which is Arnold's house where
Dolores made her allies made tracks
Dolores through the underworld
eventually going to yakuza headquarters
this is hidden within an area called the
itard ocean distillery which i've
definitely just butchered sorry guys
don't come after me the location is
hiding a true location within it and
this could be a reference to the
simulation within a simulation that may
be going on but there are also ties from
this episode to the building's name
itself in buddhism a tired ocean means
to be of the same mind even though we
are in many bodies this metaphorically
also relates to hale and Dolores who we
learn in this episode are one in the
same and it's also reflected in William
who is dealing with an identity crisis
maybe easily dispatches the gods there
as they a weapons that are equipped with
AI programming and she comes face to
face with the leader of the group it's
revealed that he is a host that Dolores
has created he resembles mushishi from
Shogun world and we discovered that
Dolores is well aware of the plot by
suruc against her maven the hosts battle
it out with their blades but Musashi
winds and stabs her in the stomach
leaving her to die now a group of forces
do show up just as Dolores is about to
kill Maeve and these are likely surak's
men Mavis we know from the trailers
sticks around so I do think it's a safe
assumption to make
at the party Dempsey is intercepted by
Stubbs and Bernard before Dolores and
Caleb can get to him the guns come out
and Dolores and stubs go head-to-head in
the best action scene of the season thus
far
canal's captures bernard and caleb
chases Dempsey down and we learned that
Dolores has been using duplicates of her
personalities in the hosts now as we
discussed earlier the one inhale may
have been the wide aspect of her
personality and last week this is why
she took a lot of joy
killing there was of course a lot of
symbolism for this lace throughout the
episode last week such as the yin and
yang symbol and Dolores stating that
hail came from her Dolores wishes to
build a new world for the host but if
you want something done right you've got
to do it yourself
Dolores captures Dempsey and the episode
ends with the man in black white being
confronted by Dolores who is donned her
Westworld regalia now I do believe that
this is a hallucination
and this manifestation of her is where a
lot of his guilt lies Dolores was really
the person who arguably had the most
effect on William in his life and the
house made him realize who he really was
William as we know has been haunted by
his own psychosis and he now believes he
is further trapped in a reality and must
get to the bottom of it
the end of the game is him questioning
whether he's a host or not and if he
does not know does it really matter it
leaves us to think that perhaps the
human should have treated the AI is
equal instead of their slaves which they
could use and abuse in whatever way they
saw fit this has led to an uprising and
now the humans are the ones stuck with
the identity crisis over what's real and
what isn't rather than the hosts it's a
somber note to end on and next time it
looks like we are finally seeing
Rehoboam creation and how the algorithm
was made in order to keep everything in
line it does look like everyone is
quote-unquote waking up and this may
indicate that people are finally
realizing the world that they exist in
this fake it definitely has an escape
from the matrix vibe to it so it does
indeed add a lot of weight to the theory
overall I really enjoyed the episode and
the season is continuing to keep me
second-guessing I have so many theories
so little time but I'm definitely
enjoying the slow burner this is
providing now obviously I'd love to hear
your thoughts on the episode and what
you took from it comment below and let
us know and if you enjoy this video then
please drop a thumbs up and make sure
you check out a breakdown of the series
this fall which is gonna be linked at
the end if you want to support the
channel from as little as 99 cents a
month to please click the join button
below
we massively appreciate it and as a
thank you you get access to content
early if you want to come chat yourself
this show either follows that definition
YT or click the disc or link in the
description below every month we give
away free movies to people are subscribe
to the channel and this month you can
win the Star Wars Skywalker saga box set
and all you have to do is comment on a
video and make sure you sub with no
patience on the more videos to comment
on the more you have a chance of winning
so make sure you get involved the
winners gonna be chosen at random on the
15th of April and the cell be shipped
out from then - ever gets the prize it's
the best of luck to everyone who takes
part this is a channel for people who
are never missing television so if
that's the kind of thing you like you
need to subscribe to definition thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time take care peace